virer un mot devenu réalité pour
fabienne de ceux en juillet 2016
licenciés économiques par une radio
locale le titre de son livre trois ans
plus tard recueil de chroniques tiré de
son quotidien de chômeuses incassable
coaching pour tous made in pôle emploi a
levé 7 45 ans se réveille avec une
petite séance d'exercices pour booster
notre motivation
à 9h15 on se met au boulot pour trouver
du boulot pendant 2h45 alors la mère
d'un héros mère basque normalement il
faut 20 minutes pour faire le tour et le
programme est terminée on vous dit aller
sur des sites pour faire des séries
parce qu'il faut les faire comme si les
lendemains faut le faire comme ça et
vous voyez des cv avec on voit juste la
poitrine d'une femme et on dit prenez
moi et c'est ça qui font envoyer pour
trouver un employeur c voilà c'est quoi
les compétences c'est quoi l'intérêt
donc voila quand je réagissais à quelque
chose dont je fonce poussé mon coup de
gueule
j'avais un petit coup de mou ben ça
pouvait être un petit peu mou quand ça
me faisait marrer ça dépend des de
l'humeur en fait au moment de son
licenciement fabienne à 47 ans et des
enfants 5 à charge à l'époque dans une
famille recomposée
alors perdre son salaire même d'un
emploi à temps partiel est un coup dur à
la maison et n'a pas fini de payer donc
oui c'est un flip parce que même si
c'est pas des sommes de dingue
pour nous c'était déjà énorme et et moi
je savais que mon profil fin normalement
j'allais strictement aucune chance à
leurs cépages avait pas vraiment de
chance de trouver un melon fixe là où
j'avais un profil pour lequel
l'administration se retrouvent souvent
impuissante pour l'emploi ce complice
d'un fortune qu'elle surnomme presque
affectueusement paulo aujourd'hui tout
se fasse par internet vous envoyez vos
documents on prenait rendez-vous alors
oui j'ai vu un peu des gens au départ
j'avais la chance entre lui même et un
licenciés économiques d'être en
contraste sécurisation professionnelle
ce qui implique normalement ou à
quelqu'un une fois par mois
bon pour garçons se verrait assez vite
rendu compte qu'on pouvait pas
grand-chose pour moi il m'a fait
confiance et ça c'était pas d'année
aujourd'hui fabienne n'a pas retrouvé
d'emploi fixe mais elle a décidé de
poursuivre ses envie d'écrire un second
livre consacré au dessin de presse est
attendue cet automne